here's a tip for remembering which  amendments to the constitution do what  specifically  the prohibition amendments now i will  never forget which amendment does what  what uh institutes prohibition and what  repeals prohibition  because i have a mnemonic specifically i  know that the amendment that created  prohibition was the 18th amendment  because  18 years old used to be the drinking age  in america but it's not  anymore so that is what got rid of  drinking and  i know that the 21st amendment is the  one that repealed prohibition because  that is the  current drinking age in america so now  you know and you will never forget which  amendment does what with respect to  prohibition and drinking in america